[Music]
you took you took a trip to Europe
recently I did
oh you have a nice time there I loved it
I just smoked a lot of weed and went to
a lot of museums you'd get stoned and go
to me and then go to museums I mean
that's what makes the museums for but
they got a lot of weird museums in other
countries like Stockholm Sweden they
have the okay Stockholm is in the house
I should have expected - we got a lot of
Stockholm people did you do well they
would know that there they have the
Swedish Hall of Fame which is just Apple
and literally just about small a little
exhibit from the that Swedish Chef from
the Muppets and the Swedish Chef from
the Muppets I guess he was a pretty good
rapper yeah so what else do you go to
those museums museums yeah so you go to
the museum and that's all you would do
is go to music oh no I go to museums and
then I you know I go out to drink and
and have fun and then also I go I mean
my out of my annual pilgrimage that I
make começo what you always do Mecca
yeah you went to Mecca mm-hmm really
yeah yeah that's that's the the
religious site Mac oh no no Amsterdam oh
my head Mecca hello the hot head Mecca
oh yeah okay I don't know if you know
this but I like marijuana yes
like getting a hug on your inside so
what do you do when you're in Amsterdam
must want amuse them there they have the
marijuana museum yeah I go there to pay
my respect right yeah yeah they actually
have actual marijuana plants in the
museum which means this is the best
museum ever yeah and then also the gift
shop is great it's just beanbags and a
half I got to ask you something you
worked with Justin Timberlake on the
movie trolls which is coming out in
November Sweden got a bigger applause
than Justin Timberlake they're looking
for their Pokemon character kind of half
watching us and like I've been doing the
same
you